dans un peu moins d'un mois le coup
d'envoi de l'euro vous le savez pour les
trois ans à venir les consommateurs
continueront de payer leurs achats en
francs mais dès le 1er janvier prochain
les banques et les grandes entreprises
commenceront à travailler à facturer en
euros voyons comment les commerçants se
préparent à ce passage qui se fera
progressivement pour beaucoup leurs eaux
annoncent une baisse des coûts donc des
prix jérôme soûlard sylvain gauthier
l'europe un autre monde 350 millions de
consommateurs qui dans 26 jours
exactement pourront enfin payer en euros
avec leur carte bancaire ou un nouveau
chéquier surpris sur ce petit marché
strasbourgeois
car cette première révolution monétaire
pourtant très proches n'inquiète pas
grand monde que les gens payent en euros
et en livres sterling franc français
l'essentiel c'est bien sûr d'être payé
et pour le reste on verra bien
malheureusement il ça va nous changer la
vie je pense que c'est important mais
dix ans dans le pratique quotidien ça va
pas être la révolution des commerçants
serein mais des banquiers très préoccupé
par second big bang informatique
le passage du franc à l'euro les
dernières choses à faire ce sont les
adaptations logistique c'est à dire
implanter le nouveau logiciel qui
tourneront à la fois en france et en
europe pour justement faire face à cette
période de trois ans la période de
transition
le 1er janvier à 13h ce telex affichera
donc la valeur exacte de l'euro
immédiatement toutes les transactions
boursières et bancaire se feront en
monnaie européenne une première bonne
nouvelle paraît-il pour nous les
consommateurs
le consommateur et de temps en temps
épargnants donc pour la consommation
quotidienne évidemment cette europe
n'existe pas encore mais quand on fait
des économies sur les taux d'intérêt
quand on place son argent au niveau
européen et non plus au niveau
domestique
on est concerné dès le 1er janvier 90 en
démonstration dans cet hypermarché tous
les produits importés de la zone europe
seront achetés en euros sans commission
ne change à payer
résultat l'addition va baisser ça
pourrait de toute façon se répercuter
sur le prix du consommateur vu qu'on
achètera moins cher on pourra forcément
rendre moins cher autre exemple le prix
des voitures bientôt affichés partout en
europe plus question pour les
concessionnaires français de vendre
ouvertement la même automobile 10 à 20%
plus cher qu'en espagne par exemple nos
prix comme les prix de tous les
constructeurs vont converger en europe
c'est à dire que les écarts de prix qui
était de l'ordre de 35% il ya quatre ou
cinq ans sur certains produits demain
seront de 5 à 10% et à terme ils seront
les mêmes sur l'ensemble de l'europe des
avantages sans inconvénient pour
l'instant car c'est en 2002 seulement
que nous consommateurs devront apprendre
à utiliser au quotidien
cette nouvelle monnaie